all right and we are live the last word
with Laura Cognito and he bounces hot by
the campfire what is going on sir man it
has been an insane week since we had
Tassie on last week if you did not catch
that episode go back listen to last
week's episode
Paul Tassie from Forbes awesome to have
him on here great guest at some point
we'll see if we can get him back on here
but man he plays about as much as we do
he's he's he's in it so he knows the
stuff it was an awesome chat they all
had a great I was a fantastic episode
badass he was on fire it was great man
it was it was honor to have him you know
saying I can't find deaf like he said he
with God we got to get him back man that
was so much fun
so much fun got the chat in here
everybody's lively a lot to talk about
man destiny what's going on what isn't
going on this has been like information
oh oh man so crazy so crazy since we
have spoken last let me see if I can
cover everything that have been said we
got director's cut part three three cuz
you are alive so that was literally like
12:01 my time on Friday then Gamescom
happened we got the gamescom trailer we
got the game on interview we got the
seasonal trailer we've got the
GamesRadar article oh my god and at the
inside xbox they want inside yeah that
was like all over man oh yeah
they were busy mm-hmm so let's see if we
can do this in chronological order as we
do in most weeks if you guys are
catching this on YouTube on Twitch on
audio we are on each of those platforms
just two different times typically
record Friday morning on Twitch about
9:00 a.m. Central Standard recording
time but follow myself Lord Cognito the
last word podcasts all of us on Twitter
in case times change we're also gonna be
on video on both of our YouTube channels
on iron Lords podcast any montes YouTube
channel but if you don't like the video
or you prefer to take us on the go we
are on your audio platform of choice
Spotify Google Play iTunes and most of
the others so Rock we are
we're bopping thank you but we are we're
lots of places so if you're looking for
so you can find us but we get a lot of
topics to discover but the first one is
gonna be director's cut part three now
this is one where I want you in it
because this is this is your baby you're
late none yeah I'm glad you brought that
up is I got a brain I have to literally
bring it back up all mine of emotions I
mean I'll let you read and then you want
me to hate it you know I was gonna say
I'll just kind of hit the top points and
okay you know about this oh yeah so
let's see first I mean he just kept
wanting to clarify about the general
mods in the artifacts and we'll go into
all that in a little while the big thing
they wanted to clarify is we've got
damage numbers they are gonna be
changing up to damage numbers at some
point they don't want to show 999,999 on
screen so they're just gonna shrink the
numbers you're still gonna see the
health bar move the same they're just
changing the numbers and all that is is
just like a number squish they're just
bringing them down so a bit more lines
QQ yeah so if you do your damage testing
it may look like 20 instead of 40 you're
still gonna move the health part of the
same number PvP is probably still gonna
be the same and that's more of a PvE
thing the big one that we kind of get to
talking about is buffs d-bus and
stacking rules so when it comes to PvE
especially not really a PvP thing damage
stacking is huge so right now we've got
people using tractor cannons from afar
standing and well of radiance standing
with a rally barricade or Luna faction
boots mm-hmm and getting extra damage by
getting like a warlock melee to share it
with your buddies and so many ways to
stack buffs and debuffs on people that
they are melting like the final rate
boss in one face things like mountaintop
are crazy
so they're trying this is the nice way
of Bungie saying so we made it early
casual and then they're swinging the
pendulum they're like alright you guys
are gods now okay we gotta reel you back
in a little bit and see if we can kind
of settle this pendulum somewhere in the
middle
brands they basically just say one
ability buff is gonna be active on a
character at a time
mm-hmm so that is gonna be potentially
one buff whether it's word of dawn
weapons of light and well of radiance
anything for you specifically to output
damage you get one of them then on an
enemy you also get one whether it's
tether
whether it's melting point whether it's
one of the new ones from the artifact
which is kind of an interesting build
you get one on an enemy and one on you
and then on top of those two weapons
still function the same rampage still
works the same kill clip still works
Gilliam so I mean you've got a lot of
options but you can't have like six
you're gonna be limited to just one on
each so right we're trying to make and
this goes back to just the previous
topic we had I mean they built reckoning
because we were just a little too
beyond godly so they're like okay let me
try and smash you from all sides since
you can stand in your infinite well of
well of right life-giving damage great
life-giving what do you see coming out
of this I mean we've got you know like
the Lumina buff or empowering rift and
then you've also got like you know
tractor cannon or I think you know and
then we what we do no weapons of light
is coming right yeah so yeah you'd only
got all that stuff one I mean to me when
I read this the first thing that came to
my mind was fair I mean at the end of
the day you know as as destiny has
evolved with in-game content raid
specifically you know it we have seen
more and more you know once we've gotten
to that light threshold right we are
literally melting mosses like it is
we're seeing more solo stuff more than
ever and again I'm not trying to
discount the skill level a lot of these
guys because this still takes a lot of
skill to do this stuff you know but you
see them what to man stuff I mean think
about d1 d1 you can kinda like on your
hand how many times that kind of thing
would happen and it would really be
remarkable you'd be like oh my god this
guy solo you know I'm saying such and
such and dumb with d2 it's been it's
been more and more crazy yeah yes a
little more more so
thing is fair I think you know look if
I'm doing a tractor cannon you know and
guys are doing melting point at the same
time you know I think it's fair that
whatever is the most recent debuff or
you know is gonna be the one that supply
so I think I'm most powerful the most
powerful yeah yeah like if well if
radiance and it is 25% damage bonus I
don't even know the number and then
weapons the lightest 35% yoky 35% right
the only question I have with this is
they just need to be very clear on the
UI what is being applicable because we
are so used to getting all our rocks off
and just ah you know I did everything is
like multiplying and all the counters
are going so they need to give a visual
cue that if I do track the caning and
this guy know I got well or whatever
whatever is the powerful buff is in that
corner it's illuminated and people are
clear that is what's taking the most
damage other than that this is fair I
mean you said it best he standing in
well luna faction rally barricade you
know we're literally you know whisper
and whisper was whisper you don't say
like we're literally just chilling on
the other side of the map unloading on
bosses it's like you know we got we got
to get a little bit of a challenge back
so i think i don't think it's artificial
I think I think it's fair and I think
Luke explained it well so that's what
yeah so I mean I think that pretty much
covers it yeah we've got just trying to
bring things back in a check so if they
make an encounter with mechanics we can
actually enjoy it I guess and they they
wanted to play as intended not sit and
well dump damage into a boss they want
you to be like moving around or have to
use the orbs or do this thing it's not
just like they want you to go through
some of it they build these encounters
with a purpose and while you know not
every encounter is perfectly built they
are built with mechanics in mind the
idea of going through this a couple
times trying to put you know your ammo
reserves to question things like just
really kind of stretching you thin a
little bit and it we've got you know
we've got a bit out of hand so yeah
absolutely absolutely next we get to
supers everywhere hahaha
for quite a few things this is probably
more of a PvP thing but also PVE pvp -
yeah yeah yeah players just need to be
slightly more specific with their timing
is what they're going for but main EP
you've got somebody running around with
spectral blades Don blade with striker
tighten all three one for every class
are able to run around I've been killed
by the same super twice by every class
yeah and that's just those roaming
supers or bunkers so yeah they need to
reel those in I don't have been part of
that sometimes I feel like oh I just got
killed why the hell did I just spoke in
the same spot again so that's always a
bit rough yeah that's been just like I
don't know frustration for me sometimes
in PvP when it's just yeah I feel a
super I'm like oh I'm like I'm gonna
here he comes a buck you're not done yes
what about you I mean you've been
playing some crucible - yeah I mean yes
that's that's common I mean it is so
common the Roman supers you come at hit
get lit up in the spawn a bad spawn and
there goes that same super again you
know I say so I've definitely
experienced it I think the super mods
obviously contribute I think you know a
lot of the master work weapons you know
I'm saying as far as to put on the Pete
I gotta flip it now on a PvE side you
know it's it's you got flows man I mean
I can you know huckleberry or you know
breakneck and you running through trash
mobs getting orbs here and there you
know I'm running on you know chaos reach
and as soon as I get 75% I'm topping off
Rome super again super again and again
don't get me wrong it is fun I'm not
gonna act like it's not fun it is there
but at the end of the day like for a
little bit of balance again these are
nurse that I understand but definitely
back to PvP you know all Roman supers
last a little too long and they're just
too too strong I guess that's my thing
like again Luke said it best that your
reaction should never be oh my god run
from everything - every single server
just like let get me out of here yeah
exactly I can remember one time
in d1 Alice when Sun break a Titan debut
if you heard that claim you know yeah
get out of here how that was like the
fire alarm get out of town
he's coming you know so like now every
super is that like every super is get
out of town it's crazy so um yeah man at
the end of the day they gotta do
something about it we have to make it a
little bit where you know skill is
involved with handling them when it
comes to health and stuff like that so
that you have a shot and that you have
to use super skill that you just can't
just okay I got my super everybody stand
back I'm here now you know kind of thing
like III I love his mindset with the way
he described how he wants to him what
did you feel about it I mean all in all
it seems good
they also stayed I mean I think that's
the biggest thing you stayed is when you
hear supers and especially if you look
down like no amamiya logo somebody got
smoked and it's just like it's a one
time and that was like a striker Titan
used to be is like the one BAM and you
were out and you know so you had to be
strategic and tactical with it but you
had to make sure you could get close
enough to use it so there's a strategy
of like getting to them now you can just
run up to them still be in your super
I'm not gonna die mode and then get your
jump off and then go running off to
chase somebody else so they wanted to
make they need to bring like roaming
supers like that need to be pretty weak
you need to use them strategically you
need to you can't just look wish wish
wish and like knife swipe across the map
just to get to summer getaways like
retros good luck good luck with dad I
shot jump and hop and blinkin it don't
matter they gonna get you like said
Freddie's like paragon Greaves run
towards the supers come on put my knee
right into your face what's a super
skill but there goes all my kills just
gotta be strategic I mean it's they've
they're out there I will say on a
counter to this and something I wish
they would just leave in there I wish
mayhem was always there you love me em
you love oh we never just want to burn
off steam it is so
much fun it is I wish it was just one of
those that could always be an option
because if you're just like hey I want
to go you know do quickly do control
it's fine I'd sort of blow stuff up and
see crazy fire like it's literally like
you get off work you have a crappy day I
just want to go nuts right now I don't
want to think that hard like that's
that's I think a mode that is it is so
much fun if they want to reel back in
everybody kind of having a lot of super
fun it'd be a nice way to balance that
having the mode sitting out there mayhem
I realized how much I missed mayhem in
the infancy stages of deed too but we
had to double primary you had the no rep
and roles oh my god and when we got him
the super yet we had the super slow meta
when you have to put exacts going to get
recharged rates faster remember that and
that week the day kind of debuted and I
was just like yo this is what I'm
talking about like let's get crazy let's
get loose you know I like that idea I
didn't miss it yeah it's a bowl me
personally I miss um supremacy I miss
the pharmacy a lot because I've always
felt like it discouraged camping and
spocs cuz you in order to for the credit
you have to don't get it you know I'm
saying so I like that and then it was
like it also rewarded multi kills
because um you know you get a group and
they just clean up and get those crests
shack talk about them Christmas I think
is me excited like who shags talking at
talk but you know the boat but yeah am I
feel you on that depth in there and then
said Fred sent it to and I think this is
one of the things that's gonna be tuned
is the chaining of the supers the orbs
actually giving orbs to your part like
if you start chaining supers it tidal
wave yeah and not a whole and then it
just you get just rolled steamrolled the
entire time when they start chaining
together and there's a strategy to that
but there's yeah there's not a great way
to come back from that either exactly
because if the teammates are running
together and they're picking a couple
orbs each and then all of a sudden
starts changing one some one person in
your team may get a super but somebody
on the other team's got like two more to
counter it so the other rough part
there's nothing more demoralizing than
playing comp
you're going against a team that's
chaining and then you look up
at the top of the information bar and
you see those supers lit up on the
opposing team and you like you still got
a deal with three boys super or whatever
it is yeah it's very demoralizing mm-hmm
so yeah that will hopefully be a good
change and I'm okay with it as well so I
think it'll be good next we've got heavy
mo the other side of this PvP coin and
they actually they're going old-school I
mean I want you to break this one in
because some of your stuff so yeah they
surprised me man let us know what is
happening yeah basically said you know
that it's become an in match rally point
you know once open players nearby would
get all the heavy he said heavy ammo is
a jockey for position speed before and
out man get out of here
this guy here knows well I'm gonna
shoulder charge you out of the way man
get out of here so you know that he's a
desti 1/2 heavy ammo fell meter and in
dusty 2 you can defeat a team but not an
art Titan mow the woods with a brick for
up for a hammer so where's his heading
so basically talks about making heavy M
will be communal in 66 playlists he also
reduced the amount of ammo per brick in
PvP for certain 6v6
archetypes it's not exactly the same as
the one when a player cracks open the
heavy crate other players have a window
of time to interact with it to get their
heavy ammo so that's the that's the
initial change and at first I was like I
don't know right do you think you this
before you think to more what forever
one place or one per team like old d1
cuz he was like split up everybody get
their stuff oh then they go back to
normal a normal yeah this is gonna be
interesting
I don't know me I don't think there's a
right or wrong answer until we play it
but I definitely feel here's my problem
playing it with you mountain top guys
I'm done just dude I've I've gotten to
the point
a God did appoint ways like I've given
up on getting heavy and crucible give it
up because I'm either in the flow of a
match if I'm not closed during the
natural flow then I'm just like all
right such a such guy you look at the
bottom who such as such grab such as
such and you see the icon alright that's
it for me
you know say I've got matches where I've
gone multiple matches where I've not
gotten heavy yeah I mean I'm doesn't
happen
I can go four or five matches without
getting heavy because it's just a being
again you have to be cognizant that it's
common and then even if you are there's
nothing more demoralizing than going in
you see in that guy to detent out I've
seen do is put emotes of them sitting
there you know we need a capital they
said like I've seen those do that Friday
I'm like you ridicul I said you know it
gave man you wanted that you get is the
same I never in that I don't you you you
were very respectful no I mean I was
like I'm sorry I'm coming in taking this
at least now it's like okay the people
who can actually get a shot and be more
communal and get it I kind of like that
I just got to see how it plays out you
know if they're gonna do it sounds like
they're gonna do just the one area in
one I wonder on how that's so that's my
one worry is if you did one mm-hmm
the whole damn team is gonna get it and
then the whole team has heavy and the
other team does not and then your I so
like that if they bring it back in a
communal fashion with because that was
the thing about having one middle
central brick to fight over one person
would get it yeah that one person was a
little terrifying for a little while but
it wasn't the whole damn team he could
be like alright we'll pop in heavy
alright go grab your brakes and like
four people on one side get heavy and
nobody on the other team that's not even
that's just like walking into Omaha
Beach you're just like screwed yeah I am
worried so I am worried about that if
they bring it I think they have to do it
for both so I don't know but wait a
minute let me ask you this if I recall
Howell's had one or trials had to try to
remember it so long Troutman away so
long I can't remember I'm not the person
asked on the trials people in a chat
went Roswell Sarge d1 what when the
heavy round came was it - it may have
been to them in to areas where each team
got to Yuka meet and address yeah he's
round three right yeah both teams would
like agreed not to pick it up because
both teams were do you know yeah it was
- it was - okay okay trials have - one
more match but both sides got it well
both sides guy that's my question like
did both it has to be a level playing
field it has right yeah now let me read
it though did he say did Luke say that
it will be he said it will be communal
and 6v6 but he didn't specify that one
of both no teams well held that that's
gonna be my question because everyone
team does that I mean you could just
have two people go mop the the other
team up with heavy to people who have
heavy hold down the heavy right right
depending on how far you say it's gonna
be both teams cuz the only thing he's
could do D this key sentence he says is
it's not exactly the same as the one
though and then what he differentiates
it is when a player cracks open the
heavy crate other players still have a
window of time so let's say you're late
you yo oh good I'm getting there I'm
getting there
you still got a cloak out down to get
you still be able to grab it I'm gonna
assume I would be shocked that it's not
both Tyrion and then also made for some
RIT like some of the best moments is
when the other team was going for it and
you're like all right screw it I'm not
going for the heavy I got my noble bomb
up I'm gonna go get a 5 stack I'm on it
I forgot about them days those were
funny moments because like you could go
through and Twilight cap go underneath
in the tunnel and come back just smash
them all cuz they're right in that
little buildings ask when super play was
huge for that right a bad house good I
mean and that'd be a point where you're
waiting for have you got 5 seconds and
then you hear that hammer and you're
like well crap yep the matter what it's
gonna be a little more strategic
so mm-hm I hope it's that way and I
think you're successful if they do
that's gotta be there's no way it's just
one
I'll be shocked we'll see yes
PvP and this is one that they've had and
they state it's like there's been a lot
of conversations internally and
externally at different points during
the year support budget around the
support punji provides PvP on one hand
we've continued to tune the game each
quarter added pinnacle weapons which
somehow ended up being a difficulty try
it out a ranking system and crucible
which they say raking it's kind not
really but it's kind of there yeah it's
not like ladders and true ranks and you
know tears and anything returned the
game to 6:56 on the other hand we
haven't released a new permanent
game-mode many game modes from destiny
wanted nowhere to be seen
there was no public facing PvP team and
the last thing they said trials was on
hiatus and on top of that we haven't
seen any maps so we've had yes they've
been tweaking it but they've been trying
to they've been trying to recapture the
destiny what magic is mostly what I
would say we're at and I think one of
the biggest things for you very
specifically italicized word yes I got
that paragraph when when you're ready
okay cool just yeah yeah alright they've
I mean they've experimented and they're
gonna go through some playlists and
changes and things like that but all in
all PvP has been just one of those
things they are not entirely sure when
they want to do with it I think mmm and
this is gonna come back to I think
destiny to came out then we had curse of
Osiris kind of tank war mind was okay
forsaken was good but you lost a lot of
people with the release of d2 you know
like hey what's this annual Osiris I'm
out and people just stopped I mean I
then plot the player graph has to be
just a cliff I was at his lowest point
that was that as well as point now when
we started this podcast on it yeah so
smart we were so good right time right
we it feels so sweet though it feels so
sweet because we started flashpoint aka
the last word
um right at that time right post Osiris
gonna say I'm gonna say post Osiris
which was like war mine it was January
or February it was right but yeah
pre yeah we love Osiris the lowest level
we were at people were like what in the
hell are you doing it asked me but that
game is dead what is wrong with you and
we like huh so that's why I feel sweet
to be still doing it you don't say and
I'm to see where it's coming but um yeah
that everything you said those were
points of contention those were issues
um yeah you know he still seems like
he's you know try they're still trying
to figure out I mean obviously they have
a plan for shadow keep I cannot wait to
see that implementation but let me know
when you're ready for that next
paragraph good I don't know I'm getting
there getting there is very important
word chop chop it so the biggest things
that they're doing is they are obviously
we've had six has come back mmm
comp is still force but the biggest
thing is they're changing up the
playlist and this is one of the things I
thought they were gonna be doing and I
also think the the PvP team has probably
had a hard time with some of this
because you have people wanting certain
playlists or game modes to come back and
they have the weekly rotators but they
cannot do quite a destiny one situation
I don't think they've been able to
because I think they worry a lot about
their player base being split up way too
much right and in the queues let's be
honest like that you you have so many
different molds in their defense
you are definitely killing that yeah so
if you fragment your player base people
gonna be mad about long wait times and
then some game-mode still may not have
that many things in it and stuff like
that so they've been trying to wait and
something about new light as it's gonna
be a free game is a really gonna help
get that influx hopefully as they state
a lot of new players coming in which is
going to give all the playlists a decent
size population boost well really gonna
help them allow to hey if you want to
pick this mode you can a little more and
I think this is all it's coming together
at a good time and hopefully with many
new players yeah it's like come I think
they also said there's gonna be a
blueberry like matchmaking curve you and
I are gonna pair up let them play with
us
come on no but I thought they state
I'll show you the way you'll put an ace
of spades in the middle of their eyes
exactly but yeah so we've got some
playlist changes couple that I'm
insanely pumped about so let's go
through these biggest thing they're
going back to a common number of three
there's a couple for playlist that will
be in there yeah we except my paragraph
we did with the trouser to the trials we
get there at the end on that that's the
big no we've got a build I'm gonna have
a climax for this okay I gotta calm down
I got a relaxed I'm not gonna do it
don't ask the boy I'm dying but let us
talk about the molds let's get back on
track focus then Yeltsin so they are
bringing it back to a common number of
threes in those places they can we're
gonna have six is in a lot of places
competitive is gonna get some tweaks but
the playlists are gonna look as follows
quick playing competitive or gone off
the director quickly is gonna be called
classic mix basically it's gonna be
basically like it is today control clash
but supremacy is in there too so you
asked for it and you got it coming so it
is nice to have that in the mix because
sometimes you're like hey I got control
I got clash Oh supremacy you it does
change the way you move it does change
the way you have to play because I mean
you take one of the emissary maps out
there and that tends to be a very ranged
map with scout rifles and snipers and
people picking each other off if you get
supremacy there for one that's probably
gonna be a slow map but - yeah it's like
it'll play differently for sure mmm
competitive is replaced by 3v3 survival
thing oh god they got rid of getting rid
of lockdown they're getting rid of it's
literally just the only good mode that
people it's like okay survivals fine
it's like you know best of lives or
whatever it's the best version of that
you can get in there yeah and then mine
this is my little favorite
survival soloqueue iOS that adds glory
we got a lone wolf lorry playlists like
what I don't have I don't think they've
ever done that they've ever done that
now let's break this down way survival
solo queue playlist so tell me alright
we you're just running so there's no
team play yeah everybody or the other no
it's not singer it's not like Rumble not
Rumble but it's like it's basically over
killed nobody
yes I like that yeah like I mean it I
like it balances it out and then it's
like it may use voice chat it may not
but you don't have a three stack core in
it against solos yeah so that was how
its police though nothing got you in a
sense there let's say we're in the party
no like week so I guess it is it like is
it policed by the minute you're in a
fireteam it's gonna say no you're in a
fireteam you cannot queue up this list
yeah no I mean that's gonna be like
you're gonna have to go in by yourself
there's been like certain missions and
stuff you have to queue up you cannot
queue up in a fireteam and it's gonna be
can't queue up in a fireteam so yeah
same thing right you know right that's
gonna be fire that's me I'm a behavior
it so they've added a 6v6 control to its
own playlist controls like home base for
Destiny's PvP control and getting the
points that's gonna be there with the
new influx of players this fall we want
to have a playlist that signals to new
players this is where to start
feel like 66 control is a good place and
they've also added 66 rotator and a 4 V
4 rotator so you've got like clash
supremacy mayhem
those will probably be out in 66 and
then lock down and count down on the
force but those are not gonna be for
glory anymore they're just the play
style and I don't know a lot of people
that love those too so the fact that
we're kind of getting those two separate
school and if you go between clash
supremacy and mayhem 466 I'm cool that's
a decent school that's cool
so all in all that's those are good
things and I don't think this is
something they could have really done
and
they could count on a big influx of
players and is that still says destiny
to the free new lights really the only
way they were gonna do that I mean
shadow keeps amazing don't get me wrong
yeah absolutely but for people who
haven't been playing destiny to in a
while I've seen so many people on my
social media who are not destiny fans
redownload in the game or say hey as
soon as I've told my first comms I'm in
I'm here and I'm saying new light yeah
and it states - it don't be a thing but
yeah these modes Jesus this is crazy man
this is this is crazy then removing
underperforming modes and maps and
underperforming maps - yeah I'm curious
to see which ones get the X that's gonna
be fun then we've got this is gonna this
is the building to yours I'm getting
there yeah cuz you skip my parrot no no
no I'm this is this has been there's a
plan there's a madman so they said
they're also working on four variants of
3v3 elimination now this is gonna be in
crucible labs so you're not gonna get a
lot from it per se but elimination is
gonna make its returning crucible labs
however elimination is very much
unfinished missing voice over there you
know unique medals associated with it
and there's four different variants and
they're trying to figure out what tweaks
on it is gonna work the best and I'm
honestly very curious how it goes so as
3d 3 elimination is in the works there's
a very specific line and I'm gonna pass
the torch back to you because you're
gonna jump out of your chair and through
your monitor to kill me if they know
what is what does Luke say specifically
I'll let you read that line I don't even
know what to do with that okay there was
some really so he's talking about a
previous amount everybody loved there
were some really cool parts to the
emissary and we actually got some lore
behind her with the drifter yeah I mean
that was a very interesting like there's
there's some big crazy galaxy scale
level stuff going on mm-hm
some of the gear was pretty potent sub
darkest before but the theme felt weaker
in the trials card was less important
and mistakes no lower
trials of the nine didn't work the way
we'd hoped and trials of the nine in
italics
on a hiatus indefinitely year that is
this that is a very important thing
because trials of the nine the word nine
is in italics so that mode is gone
but if they they are there is something
working so now it's all yours
he's coming it's probably doubt they
call it Osiris again he is coming I
don't think they're gonna call it Osiris
again listen he went out of his way to
destroy that one sock psycho chick from
the remember Sarah she's out of here now
that's it you've had you've had your run
we tried your mold for before we didn't
like it
the mats we liked it so it's just like
here's the thing this was funny to me
this is but like when I saw this alright
let's see where he's going with it and
he's literally saying everything I said
it just didn't work it didn't work from
up from a massive Fanta cops are still
here what's going on - cops - oh yeah a
library they don't like trials of the
Nancy but anyway trials of Osiris is
coming back he's jet the thing is the
crucible Labs is gonna be the setup
because 3v3 elimination is trials so
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
tweak either tokens rez time let us play
with that and then give us the feedback
so I personally think this was cool you
know I'm saying I think what they
realize is that for in order to bring
trials of Osiris back the way it needs
to be it's two part it's a law part and
it's the mold part the mold part they've
already said to us hey we don't like you
know we don't think that the old trials
would translate well you know I'm saying
in you know 2019 right crucible labs is
what they're doing with us with that
that's literally what that it that's
like Google go mess with it see what you
like now what I did is I posed this
question to um fire team chat they had
actually shout to odd Esalen Gary you
got to tweet up I guess they were gonna
meet a bungee and they say hey if you
guys have any questions you know let me
know and one of the questions I said was
that honest I'll get your wood I got you
lesson
she said is that you know you know what
you know some question I said what any
things I asked him was pretty much like
look if Cruz will Labs and the fan base
says this is what we want and it's
literally a mimic of trials are you guys
as bungee now gonna come back and say
you know what this is the mode they won
cuz that was the rhetoric they try to
spit on us in the beginning he they were
trying to tell us that that modes not
viable anymore in 2019 in its if it
stayed in the same iteration I call BS
on that I call BS on that because at the
end of the day if crucible labs and we
get our hands on it and everyone's
joined three weeks rest tokens and maps
designed for it right and as far as the
theme he Luke is literally trashing
trials of the nine from a thematic
standpoint how it just didn't feel cool
he mentions that he doesn't even like
the car they didn't have the card system
all these things are Cyrus thinks
there's no doubt he's coming back it's
just they have to do it correctly and
let's be honest curse had such a stain
on it that he needs a grand return so
that is no doubt move on would you would
you think let me get a ward then I get
look he said if it so excited you
realize that we have to deal with the
fanboy Provenge you're right yeah bro no
I don't like he's heavy kool-aid
drinking now and he's got a pretty chain
they trash his narrative they that net I
don't know who was doing narrative at
that time it was bad it was even the
book man did you smell the book in this
book this one I got to remember that an
issue Osiris story and they left
you know the tower and then secure ins
like laters and I'm like fam you cannot
be saying laters like it just doesn't
work it like you not come on you're not
the cool ghost so again that I think
they realize somatically there has to be
a lot of change and also let's be where
has he been
you gotta explain we got vex going on
he's an orphan it forests do its thing
trying to
the Vexin check the vex is running loose
right now and shadow keep Betsy's well
he's not gonna be back for this one
well you're not coming back but I'm just
saying like they we've literally been in
this area he's supposed to been in for
like three expansions we had the revelry
we had the Haunted thing we've been
running around and we don't see this man
we put in pushing random buttons on the
random level generator and be like oh
let's do this looks like cavalry put the
button on there haunted forest
exactly they gotta figure out the right
time but I think I think it's but you
let me let me let me hit it Brett - bad
news for me let me hear you
tear down my dreams and tell me why I'm
not getting Osiris back I mean I just
don't think they they they Eve they have
learned they've tried to learn and
evolve from what's been done before
and while trials of the nine didn't work
I think if they bring it back unless
they specifically have an Osiris story
to tell which I'm not entirely sure I
think they would have a way to
everything could will function the exact
same way mm-hmm but I just don't know if
they're gonna call it if they're gonna
theme it to Osiris cuz he has that
stigma but also in something where
they've never really truly copied
something from d1 and put it in d2
they've had a twist they've had a change
they've had then they'd they want to
make it distinct so I think if they do
bring it back I just think for them as
they've tried to continue to evolve the
world it would be it could function the
xane way with a vendor cards rewards
everything like that but it just I don't
see that that coming back I could be
wrong no let me ask you this you know
I'm not letting why is it okay that
Saladin can keep coming back every year
with his same old stuff and yeah they
make tweaks to it but Saladin who runs
the tournament can come back five but my
man trials of Osiris with the hot
Egyptian gear and coolest Lord most
powerful wala he can't come back in his
existing phone there's no way what's go
salad again me but no no problem you
come through we make a section for you
at the tablet it's you come up the steps
we got the velvet rope for you but mom
make a gate don't look
please explain I don't have an answer
I'm just saying bungee continues to
evolve so if they're going to like build
something new there may be a completely
different reason for it that's all they
could do Osiris if actually bring him
back it would be nice to see him get a
little bit of love because yeah he got
shafted pretty hard so it'd be nice to
see him that way the trials of kay
somebody show trials of Rahu top to edge
for everybody all fiery oh my god yeah
you've got a lot of options
Osiris could be cool but if they don't
take it that way I think the function
will probably be similar when they
narrow narrow I don't know we honest for
longer you know and out will move on but
my question is if it happens to what you
said they reimagine in this some other
person or some other thing what do you
think happens with the Osiris guy you
think they never bring him back in but
because it's such a fail thing it's
possible I mean it was so I mean just
the word Osiris for people in density to
is like that sucked
mm-hmm it was bad sorry that what most
ancient was small mercury is just this
like I hate going there playing it all
those things trials of the ever you get
a major transaction you get a my god no
but what you guys can't tell right now
by the way so I have two Huskies mm-hmm
and my wife is working from home today
and since I'm in here I'm separate from
Enzo and he's the youngest but he's the
bigger of the two
mm-hmm but if she takes the other one on
a walk and he's here yeah I don't know
if you can hear him he's just howling
right he gets he gets really loud at
some points too it's too funny and so
Eddie you good you good yeah I got
Saladin's wolves over here and one of
them is not happy
yeah I mean like I said all I will say
is destiny
prior to Osiris curse of Osiris the
expansion I would say dark below was
probably the worst one prior not because
it was really that bad but I remember
people complain remember like you
remember like dark below got some flack
you know so I would say when it launched
would you agree a short campaign yes
he's getting louder well yeah I mean
short campaign was there I don't know
how I'm trying to think of how many
strikes we got I got like one strike
maybe right people didn't know what to
expect it was the first one and we got
something in this expanse of his destiny
with four planets and right and then it
just was a very smaller piece and it was
the first time I mean first thing we'd
seen so the president wasn't right set
and we got a strike we got a PvP map or
two but overall I mean cuz the hardcore
we loved it you know crotas raid and all
that stuff I get that but overall the
dark below is not a well-received
expansion my point being is if Eris can
come back from dark below Osiris could
come back from Christmas that's all they
got a shot that's all of it maybe longer
because they want to put some distance
you know saying because of thing but
right now they're on a good Street I
don't envision it with season of the
undying you know it may be towards the
end it may be even d3 you know I'm
saying but at some point I do believe
Isis really I've know I'm family but I
do believe Travis hours is coming back
they are very specific with the verbage
they're specifically saying that I can't
see any other person taking over a
tournament and it would make sense lore
while especially with what the VEX we
know are doing you know for the future
to protect whatever they're protecting
we will get into yeah so a couple other
things for crucible trying to hit these
quickly because we've been on this for a
while yes
they're gonna be changing up some
matchmaking and things like that they're
gonna refactor glory glory ranks and
skill match changes factoring in your
skill when you get glory gains and
losses so skill is actually going to
thing so if you're stomping people but
then you you know you go in and you get
worked a little bit you might gain or
lose a little bit more or less depending
on how it goes it's kind of an
interesting like factor to it there and
then also they do talk about just when
it comes to matchmaking it's just the
whole thing about skill matchmaking if
it's overly restrictive it's fatiguing
when every single game feels like a
sweat fest and if it's overly loose when
in you can get an entire evening of
unlucky matchmaking we just get dumped
on the whole time by terminators as they
say and it's rough because I mean
whether you're kindergardens which are
gonna be all the blueberries coming in a
new light they don't want to stop them
and I think they even state specifically
they're gonna get like a gradual like
matchmaking cur to get more and more
into the normal mix there they're trying
to and this is what they stated and this
is kind of what I expected they're
working on the foundations they're
working on playlists they're working on
some matchmaking stuff they're testing
modes they're trying to change the way
heavy works and that's one of the things
I wondered about yeah all of those
things are fundamental PvP things as
opposed to trying to introduce a new
mode or anything like that right now so
we're net doesn't seem like we're
getting new modes doesn't seem like
we're gonna be and we still have the
reveal coming I think with the cart with
regards to there you know we still have
a PvP reveal that's sometimes before the
end of August I think because then pax
is soon so all that stuff is coming but
I don't think maybe they're gonna reveal
but I think they're just gonna maybe
reveal the changes they made so we'll
see maybe there's gonna be a new mode
maybe they bring back rift that's about
the only thing I could see them doing at
this point is probably bringing back
rift all along with all these changes
yeah yeah I could see it do you think we
ever get um spiral racing like that I'm
worried I don't see it anytime soon I'll
be honest I don't see that mention I
don't see them tease it really anywhere
it's just I saw row like I thought for
sure we'd have it but I'm actually
surprised that yeah I thought it would
be kind of a fun event but maybe it's
just more more effort than maybe their
numbers say it's worth it yeah just be a
numbers thing more than anything I think
mm-hmm I enjoyed it I had fun doing it
playing on control or I got pretty
fast but it was not not the same you
know what strike I miss it the one um
the the Cabal strike and um what is it
terminus not terminus no I'm in Sector
the Cabal well it's all is that the one
where you the one way you can melt the
the Cabal cap and their crushes the next
guy and then you know no probabilities
tree of probabilities that strike prior
to getting down you now you take this
barrel you go down the um yeah yeah that
reminds me of srl so much like yeah it's
a little tease but it mm-hmm yeah that
always seemed weird is like like this is
an area that we built to mess with you
to drive your Sparrow for a while but in
a strike it's just it literally consumes
time in a nightfall it's always a weird
it's a weird addition to me so mm-hmm
now this is where we get into I'm gonna
save this last topic he gets a B closing
time talking about thank you guys for
reading the evolving world piece I'm
gonna save that as we get into other
stuff because the evolving world ties
into other things
mmm-hmm so that's most of the swab and
we got big PvP changes coming we are
gonna have an involving world different
topic we'll get to in a second but we've
just got changes coming to just the feel
of the game and it's kind of one thing
iced last week before we were getting
this it does feel like you may feel a
little weaker the numbers may feel
smaller you may not feel quite as strong
and I think they just want to play that
make you play the game a little more as
intended instead of just being able to
blast through everything quite as easily
just like yeah you guys are going nuts
in chat like Byford love this by for
milan with love all the osiris landal or
stuff that's going on oh my god shot the
elbow you shut up the [ __ ] award yogurt
or sour insulin decided to be on my
brother advancing and stuff from
professionals and we're just gonna go
ahead and have that hood next time
you're gonna like layout cockney knows
cosplay for guardian context here it's
gonna be brother Vance
brother vans straight up from brother
cog man let's see he ain't doing it
right he's not giving a proper reverence
just walk you've got to have a shadow
over your head too big hood and just
walk around with your hands clasp true
story I guardian God I saw the most
Osiris cosplays I've ever seen out of
all the rest he was the most ice for two
followers and an Osiris got it on camera
check that out sauna I owe $5
yeah they got something they had to
disciple though on okay yeah then
someone was literally Oz but I was with
you when we saw on the other side no you
were talking Inouye you missed that we
sort of faked Guardian together remember
the fake gun and I got kicked off the
taro that what that cosplay but then
there was an old Syrus cosplay but you
were talking alone Oh at that time it
was right next to it over there you
missed but I got that on an Iowa podcast
yeah let's check it out in the last word
playlist it's all Guardian con
impressions and you see the little
walkthrough he's in there to see all the
good stuff good yeah but that pretty
much wraps up the Veracruz cut except
for one thing that ties into more stuff
that we've learned about and then this
week on Monday oh my god I had a meeting
on Monday to go to it like 1:30 and then
just Gamescom starts going Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam I was like are you serious
right now
I had 41 tweets on Monday Wow
41 yeah Wow so I'm sorry if I exploded
anyone's Twitter if I lost some
followers on account of that I also had
probably the most like traffic on my
Twitter that I've ever had - basically
it was like we had and I was look at
watching the reveal stream so we had the
Xbox staged the inside Xbox Bungie was
on there they did their teaser about
finishing moves which actually looked
pretty cool and we had literal frames
about like the artifacts and the moon
and like the map and all that stuff so I
literally I went back on that footage
fullscreen did recorded it in OBS and
then it went by frame by frame to try
and find okay here's what the maps looks
like all right here's the name of the
strike here's the difficulties here's
the artifact that I went through and I
was tweeting all of that stuff so I did
that and then we got the like a
cinematic thing for
the games come just like cinematic
basically which is cool so we get to see
a little bit about that we had the press
kit go out which happened while I was at
my meeting which has some crispy
pictures and a couple exotics shout out
to you shot the names put me on - yeah
and then to wrap it all up
Geoff Kili when he did the gamescom live
that man always puts on a good show
always good time we got the season
trailer so oh I'm gonna pass it to you
first and I want to say like it water
give me like two of the biggest things I
got a mute real quick yeah two of the
biggest things from just that entire
insane Monday what are your two big
takeaways first and then we'll kind of
dive in I'm just kind of curious what
you think cuz that was I was digesting
so much of it I was like I want to know
what you were thinking it was wrong you
know listen it was just information
overload and and but in a good way cuz
it's like one thing y'all like when
that's these on man it is on and this is
those times I always consider it pre
September big expansion when we're
talking you know shadow keep we're
talking we're talking taken King we're
talking before rise we're talking before
perform forsaken all those moments in my
opinion are some of the most fun cuz
you're anticipating you're getting the
information and then they have that
release cadence where they just boom
boom boom boom boom every week every day
this is coming out that's coming out
this is what we're adding that's what
we're adding and um it's really cool man
so for me first things I think they
touched it the finishing moves on the
inside Xbox stage you know I'm saying
shot the elbow yes that fact that it
would proof that Phil loves or bunging
it because we're yeah I think I want to
actually I'm glad you said that out
because I wanted to state that from the
Xbox community standpoint you know
they've always been the redheaded
stepchild
since Destiny's inception you know we
know about the PlayStation deal with arm
Activision and how the exclusive stayed
over there and oh by the way I got a
fantastic article please check it out
about this exact topic right now on
Lords of gaming dotnet please check it
out just put it up pour it on yeah so
pretty much for destiny fans it
was symbolic to see bungy on Xbox things
now I thought this would happen at 83 I
was off love about addictions I told you
I was up a couple months but it did
happen
you know said it did happen they came on
the stage and it meant a lot because
Bungie was once you know underneath the
Microsoft banner you know now they're
coming back as a separate entity kind of
a goodwill and like l-boogie said make
no mistake Phil Spencer is the biggest
destiny fan Mike Ibarra Hugh these these
are high-level execs you know I'm saying
that play des they love that game
they're testing X cloud on that game so
to have them there was good now back to
the shadow keep the shadow keep stuff
from me two takeaways finishing moves
are very cool yeah I think I'm gonna get
into that I like to risk/reward thing
that thing was cool how they broke down
it takes you know how you're super and
stuff like that and and I thought that
was good and then the the mods that coat
that you can coincide with that yeah I'm
gonna let you handle the whole thing
that that whole artifact that's you I'm
saying I know you broke it down frame by
frame I'm gonna let you get to Dow just
talk my mind it'll this will take aways
was there I go lot a got mad hype for
the season of undying trailer because
shout out to my girl I could like she
got me high sound like and I've not been
our biggest thing yeah can a day but you
know nah but I've grown up ever since
Cades death I've really started to love
my she's she's oh my you know me so like
I just like the way she talked about it
like you know about the inception the
protection and the black cause she got
me into it of what why are they so
hell-bent on protecting this thing right
now what is going on and I love the
matically how separate which mean you
predicted right we predicted shadow key
would conclude and that it this vexed
thing is gonna be completely different
oh you know from what's going on so um
yeah man this this is exciting I the
fact that they got two trailers was kind
of dope to me know what those my initial
pillars now you mister information over
mr. tweet mr. Atif a you teach me what's
going on
there's so much going on oh there's so
much going on indeed
so got first trailer was inside Xbox
they're talking about finishing moves
and first they basically state
everybody's gonna get one to start
you're not gonna have to go buy anything
you're still gonna have the function of
a finishing move no matter what you do
which is a good thing because I know
they said some people worried about
having to buy them or anything like that
now there's one straight up I'm gonna
have to buy okay with why it's the
tighten heel kick that's gonna get that
I mean dude I'm a kick boxer the
roundhouse hole oh yeah there's no way
my Titan is gonna be kicking heads off
I'm loving max oh so I saw that and I
was like crap there's whatever it is
it's mine does not matter I'm buying
that is my finishing move doesn't matter
looked so good so yeah finishing move
animations look cool so it pulls you out
into third-person perspective but the
way you know is the enemy kind of has
this lake kind of pass through it's
almost like you're like getting kind of
a line pass over of lighting and it's
also got a dot above your head what's up
your hamon first time making a podcast
what's up pins and a dot above their
head to know that they can be basically
finished now the only limitation to your
finishing is depending on basically the
cost of the finishing move what is it
gonna take to actually cast it and it
cost super energy typically so there are
different mods that will kind of bounce
some of that some will cost more some
will help balance it out and cost it
less but what you can see is you've got
a finishing move so you can basically
smash an ogre in the face you cannot do
it to big bosses right they they would
clear about that yeah but you should be
able to do it two majors and minors if
they're low enough either one should
work just not you're not gonna smash
curta sorry yeah it's gonna look at you
and be like that's cute but then the
other piece is the actual functionality
of the finishing move what it's capable
of doing so we got a couple teases the
big one they talked about is heavy ammo
so if you finish
a enemy and you have that mod equipped
now that mod is a class item mod it's on
the far right column of the artifact so
it's probably gonna take a little bit to
unlock but potentially that finishing
move can give you heavy ammo for your
whole team mm-hmm
now for the raid ideal for those
nightmare hunts whatever it is you're
gonna be going through that's you to be
able to control to get a heavy ammo drop
is huge because we don't have since
we've been missing those and finding
anyway even if it's just
oh here's the thrall well let me shoot
them a couple times and then smash them
in the face for heavy ammo even if
you're doing like random solo stuff the
control that you can have with that is
really really important mmm so that's a
big one but that's gonna cost you half
your super bar yes so it's pretty and
it's also seven energy so your class
item is not gonna have a whole lot else
going on so you're gonna go pretty
special heavy your special into that now
and you're like well that sounds good
what's better so there's another one
this is the one I figure my brother's
gonna do so the mod on the artifact
right below that one or maybe one more I
can't pick it up pull it up right now to
look but I know most of these left on
land there's one that says any void
grenade damage will weaken an enemy mmm
interesting so though what how long how
many damage ticks like stuff like that
well picture of vortex grenade probably
ticks them a little bit you'll probably
see a debuff but picture a my brother's
Titan so picture a Sentinel Titan
whether he goes Sentinel shield or ward
of dawn
he either throws the grenade first and
then pops a sentinel shield that you can
shoot through so he has the debuff on
the enemy on and the buff on you
so he'd say he's your entire damage buff
in one character yeah which is a pretty
powerful like build if you're gonna be a
support class that's a really cool thing
to do have so the same thing could do
with like pop word of dawn everybody
ready it came thrown the grenade and
weapons of light go I mean those are
certain things of warlocks could be the
same way you could throw your own
grenade and then go do a Nova bomb and
it could hit harder yeah so I mean
there's gonna be the the level of
damage damage yeah I'm curious it costs
just it's like six energy so you can't
you can't split it with anything else on
that one right so I mean it's still a
pricey one so I think it's gonna be a
decent chunk cuz void isn't one of those
that's like overly powerful it's not
like Golden Gun it's not like blade
barrage it's not gonna go big chunk of
damage from you but it is gonna help you
be more pet more beneficial right now
the weird one is for like a hunter you
can't do like a void wall and then
tether but if you do a tether and then
your tether runs out and you want more
damage above then throw the grenade a
out and you've still got a damage debuff
on the enemy so it's gonna allow people
to really go for basically that's it
yeah I was like I'm looking at it right
now almost playing a support role by
sacrificing your super take up heavy
ammo or if you're gonna go you know say
finishing move something like that
that's huge for the heavy so that's like
so you have like one person who could
have the like void grenade be that
support like damaged buff debuff one
person one or two or your heavy built
like a mowers and you can get a couple
people that are more like I'm set up
like full DPS mode going crazy suit like
more powerful survive my finishers more
frequently stuff like that right there's
it gives I mean he said it well it's
like it gives possible for a little more
diversity and builds and I think just
that last year because I went back and
watch the viaduct again from whenever
wasn't July mm-hmm and they go through
and they talk about just like the last
tier of that artifact being like nearly
exotic level mods and they are pretty
damn close to that wow that's impressive
man that's it but I want to reiterate
what this country was some one second
it's a big gaming set because um I agree
I think that he's saying I think by
giving people that choice I think
they're trying to balance people
spamming super as possibly almost like
playing a support role my sacrifice just
super to give heavy ammo
I completely agree I think that they've
come up with a cool way to make you lose
super yeah and people are gonna people
are gonna get intoxicated by the
flashiness of these finishing moves I'm
saying and then if they ground for these
rewards and these mods these specific
mods that is gonna play balance I
can completely see that and then they
kind of knock out two birds with one
stone kind of deals I completely agree
this beginning that's exactly what's
going on from a balanced perspective
yeah so it's been a lot to dive into I'm
trying to see if I can find a picture of
what this thing looks like all right so
a couple other ones we've got our four
mods we have the heavy finisher we know
and then we've got Thunder coil which is
gonna be six energy cost grants bonus
damage for all arc melee abilities and
refund a super energy on finisher final
mmm so all arc melees are stronger your
super Energy's refunded mmm but you
cannot pair that with the other one
right
they make them literally six or seven so
you're only gonna get that one that
would yeah there's a couple other that
are cool we've got arc battery grants
and / shield and reduces cooldown during
activation of all our class abilities so
I mean whether you cast your super a
grenade a melee one will make it longer
like melee and like it's just the
animation of like a punch or a grenade
throw so like if that doesn't seem that
long but I guess if you use a roaming
super which most arc ones typically are
then you get your other abilities back
so it's a way to do that also I don't
know if we mentioned before another
thing they mentioned on stream is that
there's no in there's no invulnerability
phase during these finishing rows gnome
can be killed yes so that's another
thing people have to pay attention there
is risk reward and DS was very clear I
mentioned in that dirt stream and that
may be important for somebody who does
that - maybe spec into as much
resilience as possible hello so if you
are gonna be up in the mix a little
closer more resilience is gonna be a
potentially a big thing maybe you go
invisible more frequently you set up a
bill that way it's your karnsteins maybe
get you cost me a guy so finding a way
to figure out what works best and that's
why I I hope as cool of some of these
sound that they actually do set up
different builds and make it viable I
people are gonna find like the optimal I
mean the glides are gonna be on guard
your on this year on this we're good
like they'll figure out the best but I
do think it's got potential to do some
really cool stuff so that's like that's
the fifth year right of just the
artifact so I think my last point I
think the monetization wise if they're
smart they keep adding finishing moves
different ones
eva's every season I mean could you
imagine foolishness like The Karate Kid
yeah that's so crazy with it oh you
absolutely will see those like there's
gonna be like the the one-inch punch or
something like that I'm sure oh yeah so
that'll definitely be a thing but I mean
that's an animator sitting in a corner
like one person making a money able to
do that so as an artist or the new
dances these are the new emotes trust me
oh yeah mm-hm I mean like you're going
through and you're like I want to finish
this that you're gonna have some pretty
cool pretty cool videos of those but
from what we've seen we've got the heavy
finisher there was a special finisher it
looked like I saw that which was for a
special amo finisher so you'll be able
to get some special and that was worth
like one yeah so I mean that was
definitely smaller I saw one on the
artifact which is like the freebies that
you get in the beginning your finisher
can give you glimmer right so I mean
they have some basic level ones su super
your finisher can still function and
finish up the enemy and glimmer 250
power cap still gonna be a thing worth
getting in the beginning but you've got
different options in there as well
so tier one on the artifact is pretty
basic stuff it's gonna be just like that
most of it is glimmer or vex related and
some of them seems like you get more
glimmer from killing back so it's pretty
basic stuff now level 2 and this is what
I'm gonna bring it back full circle
let's go to the evolving world so level
2 is when we get into the nightmare hunt
specific mods mm-hmm so the nightmare
hunts have three difficulties nightmare
hunts okay pull it back the new activity
on the moon is called a nightmare hunt
now you've got strikes we've had before
so get up patrols to have some activity
I don't even know it
is but the new big one for the moon or
these nightmare hunts one of them is as
I drew on the gate Lord okay whew Nats
from destiny one so the one who just got
smashed a whole bunch for many many
reasons but yes he was part of that vex
planet story and he is gonna have the
nightmare hunt is gonna have three
different difficulties the first two are
match made the third is not eight sixty
power nine twenty power rules are both
match made ninety eighty no matchmaking
so you've got power level jumps for sure
mmm-hmm and then you've also got
modifiers mm-hmm and then the modifiers
we've got eight sixty is just air
superiority quick speculation what do
you think that means go hot take five
seconds go this is all your tears appear
to jump around that's my guess yeah
really that like floating warlocks there
corresponds more powerful yeah that's
what that should actually be called flue
finches yeah so then we get into so
that's that's a depth that's the low
level then you've got hero which is nine
twenty that's gonna have still the air
superiority
you've got the it's like an enraged
version of Zhai drone I keep forgetting
the name off the top of my head because
I can't pull it up but it's like a
modifier for him okay all torment of
Zhai drone or something like that and
it's just like so the boss is just gonna
be pissed the whole time I don't know
maybe yeah is like he could who knows
he's gonna be in range the whole time
and then finally we've got two modifiers
that deal with what we're gonna be
fighting you've got champions barrier
and champions overload mmm-hmm no those
as you briefly look through I've seen a
picture of a knight that says like
barrier like barrier champion okay so
there's a specific type of enemy you
fight to get through a barrier of
something mm-hmm and there's also I
don't know if it's the ogre but there
might be the overload one but we've got
specific mods that are actually gonna
make you
more powerful against those enemies so
there's literally a mod in the second
column of the artifact anti barrier hand
cannon artifact or hand cannon and then
auto rifle and submachine both have this
as an option and these are worth zero by
the way zero cost of energy are oro
shield piercing rounds designed to
bypass combatant offensive strong
against barrier champions they're gonna
steer you to use a weapon type yes so
the anti barrier has Auto rifle
submachine gun which is one mod and then
hand cannon for another and then below
that we've got the overload and it
basically states uninterrupted fired
so some machines submachine guns and
autos can basically disrupt a over a
over overload champion or whatever right
and basically like stops their ability
casting wow it sounds like because it
says it like reduces their energy and
stuff like that so those are that's
gonna be done from bos which has got to
work different because I mean you have
the overload which is under an
interrupted fire on the auto rifle and
then you have the bows which has the
same icon so those are gonna be the
overload champions and then there's one
more which has like a square which I
don't know what it is but that's a hand
cannon one mmm so here's the big
question brings out a little circle
we've got a seasonal artifact we know it
only works for three months we've got
mods that make these new activities on
the moon nightmare hunts literally built
for that mud right at the end of your
season that artifact goes away those
mods go away and now we talk about the
possible of seasonal content going away
and it leads me to believe the nightmare
hunts are also what are going to depart
so here's the question do you what do
you think about potentially seasonal
only you know only lasting so long
content and then also this is like the
shadow keep activity and it may not last
so that's that's the big build yes there
you go with this this is when we get all
the way back to an evolving world this
Luke's final thing mmm Oh dice it up I
see what you do so here's the Paris boy
hosted today boy let's go I've been so
deep into this crap so during season
eight a new situation will unfold on the
moon and being cagey here because I am
reluctant to spoil anything over the
course of the season parts of the game
will change before the situation
culminates in an event that will
ultimately resolve it and its content
will be exhausted but this resolution
sets up the events of season 9 which
adds something new to the game and
resolves it something that will - that -
will go away but not before setting up
season 10 so we have an evolving world
of stuff of your annual pass and your
seasons that is not gonna stay in the
game you have activities that will
potentially not stay around this is it
so like he's thought he talked about the
evolving world now we see the artifacts
we see what we may be losing because the
artifact specifically works for that
mm-hmm what so how do you feel about
this first and then how do you think
it's gonna work and come on back I've
seen the chatter on the interwebs I've
seen chatter did the chat I've seen the
tiki torches I've seen the you know
pitch cops exactly and people are saying
yo like well this is me like I'm gonna
be losing content you gotta get content
and this is what I say you know and
that's why I got a sigh I gotta put my
corporate hat on that I got a sigh a
bunch yelling this here's the deal Luke
said it explicitly I believe it was
director's cut - at some point just from
a technical standpoint right
you cannot keep adding adding adding to
this game and filling up without
reaching a threshold right we've already
stated right that powerful engrams a
powerful gears good writing grants with
powerful gear the the challenges across
the map they're all way too much right
now yeah so they've already said they're
gonna be
peeling that back right now in terms of
this this seems like which but this
season specifically right with this
event that they're trying to say there's
no situation on the moon and then
something's gonna resolve it content
will be exhausted whatever whatever I
need to see that first before so this is
a little caveat I need to see what that
is I don't know what that is right so I
cannot say
chill out y'all or that because I don't
know what that is but let's bring it
back to something that we do know like
gambit prime and gambit they're telling
us well at some point one is going to go
it's not going to be this season they
said no but in here by the way
for a year they say yeah they say that's
not gonna Wow but at the same time again
stuff cannot stay forever so I
personally don't have an issue with this
and I'm saying now where I will say this
is where they may get themselves in
trouble there's only one thing I worry
about I worry about something like look
at what happened with season oculus
right they got the menagerie and we will
say for the most part - to chess not
rewarding as much can we agree that the
menagerie was a success
yeah let me say it so beloved Moe right
so let's just say we have something like
that and it's basically the evolution of
escalation protocol which was beloved
also but just didn't have matchmaker
right so I'm just worried that if we do
have another mo that is B love that that
is not part of the axing program that is
where they may get themselves in trouble
that's the only thing I'm concerned
about but here's my I think that
ultimately Bungie is smart enough to
realize that one if your engagement in
this mode is that high if people are
playing something that high that they
are not going to remove that mold I
think it's going to be one the matically
stuff that just doesn't fit to stuff
that's not performing so let's look at
what's not before I mean outside of the
Pyro's video with farming forges who's
really out here in the forges like that
anymore you know saying like there's
going to be content that they're gonna
look at and they're gonna say look the
engagement is the
hey there you know we're still gonna
give them the rewards and other sources
remember they did say that they're not
gonna take away the room so if you
wanted you that I'm just using the
forges an example you know if you wanted
your blast furnace you can get it as a
world drop or whatever whatever
somewhere else they're going to do
things like that but you know look this
is controversial I'm not gonna sugarcoat
it this is very controversial some
people are not going to like this me
personally one they were transparent
which I've always complained we and you
will always go at it right and I said if
they tell me I'm okay he's telling me
Yeah right I'm good now I can brace for
it Oh bungee you'd wake up and
escalation protocol is gone or whatever
they would just do things even like why
they do I'm saying so I just think its
technical limitations d2 is a sandbox
that it's filling up crazy memory
constraints and let's be real d3 you
know they got a prep for that as well so
I'm done rambling overall don't have a
problem with it they have to be careful
they have to listen to the community
when it's something they love that's all
I got to say the floor is yours
I mean so that brings it back to spear
said bin spear said something well the
seasons are all a cart and I think to
answer your question is as it is an
evolving world I don't think you're
gonna be able to go buy an old season
cuz you're gonna be able if you buy the
season pass you'll have access to it but
come December or January when we get to
season 9 and whenever said time comes
because as we're launching a month later
I'm kind of curious how they date this
stuff now mm-hmm
when that world finishes its culmination
and evolves yeah that old stuff's gonna
be gone mm-hmm now will depend that'll
be one of those things I think people
wonder about is like hey do I buy shadow
keep and you know the next season comes
out next week well do I buy last season
no wait a week so that'll be an
interesting thing right suicide do you
get the annual pass early or if you
don't you buy the other couple all a
cart but as that world evolves and you
wrap a storyline you wrap a piece of
lore
mmm I mean okay first speculation site
if these are the nightmare hunts we wake
something up on the moon when you go
through the Vidocq they're like it's not
gonna work the same way you can you
can't achieve victory the same way their
nightmares their phantasms they're not
real so some whatever force is causing
all of this is as a nightmare
theoretically in lore standpoint this is
a way that you can be like you're
literally fighting something in your
head right right so at some point we're
gonna have to get to that source right
and that's gonna be like the culmination
of the season and said source of
whatever we're fighting whatever
culminates in the end stops those
nightmares from happening and those
honors well thus we won't they won't be
gone so right however all that goes but
then when you come into season nine moon
won't be haunted anymore potentially
yeah that's like moons haunted maybe not
anymore because that's been resolved and
now we're on to what's next so I mean if
they do something like that they build a
more reason behind it they give you an
event as we're seeing a world of it
which is kind of cool for the game you
see an event basically go through and
then it kind of changes the way and we
have the vex invasion right now mmm what
comes next
so like if they if they put enough like
lore systems like gameplay changes
invasion of X like if you have a big
influx of changes going into night you
have a culmination event to finish up
the season I'm okay with it because if
nothing else I think that will be a cool
way for the world of destiny to like
actually see a game that involves not
just like stick another play note on the
director and stick another planet on the
dragon so I think those will be cool
yeah I just want to hit spero
yes we I hear your concern Bravo they
definitely addressed that aspect because
he's like experiment he is saying it's
like hey what they on Terrence Otakon
season eight but you don't stop play
until season 9 you can't get it they was
explicit Luke was very explicit their
reward sources the rewards is not going
away they will be dispensed in other
places so in your case if like I said
I'm gonna use black armory as an example
yeah they do you want that gun yeah
let's say yotan right and I finally got
it thank God come
you know I'm saying like say two yolks
and so say for example that was part of
that season new season comes out they
get rid of the forge and you like to ham
how am I gonna get you in the way it was
explained that will be in another source
it may be in a world rap they may put it
in another activity but you will not
lose the gear and the reward you will
lose
you know the activity on a new season
and again you know I have no problem
this is what I think part of it is cool
because narrative Lee you tell a story
some of the worst things indeed one that
I didn't like was like you know ya
stranger the Travis data tablet and you
know like you want this to be an
evolving world you want to feel like
things are changing things are happening
and you know when the red war is over I
don't want to keep seeing red war stuff
and I'm saying it's over we're on to
something else now so that I'm cooler
the only thing that I am concerned to
the chat's defense is again if there is
a mold or an activity that is beloved
that people like em trials I don't want
to hear you know saying that your wig
moving this away if the community really
stands fine that's my only thing you're
not with you when you show up your
trials guy I'm just gonna be like this
is this is the good range right here I
like that yeah bit of Spanish movie I
like that like see if there's a pl
mm-hmm but yeah I think the big thing is
you worry about and I mean I listen
another podcast you've got you know say
no to rage him and Tassie we're talking
earlier in the week and you have the
issue of introducing content that people
like too much and you relieve it like
somebody's like all the reckonings gone
ever it is like thank God
late that would you would be fine with
the forges honestly overall I mean the
journey to get to look for just was
brutal
I mean unlocking the forges was kind of
rough but the photos in and of
themselves were not a bad activity they
were repetitive they weren't that
creative but overall they were not like
I think she was dragged
I think nailed it
reckoning is the perfect example
everybody can be like say yeah exactly
menagerie everybody's like whoa whoa
whoa those are the two perfect
discrepancies yeah so does he mean
menagerie and then here's the question
and I think it was could've been lono
said it really well to say how do you
balance the activities you make so
they're good enough to be good for a
season but not so good you're worried
about them going away and you have that
balance it's like or is it just gonna be
the point we just have to accept even if
it's a bad ass activity like the
menagerie if you know we are finally
full of full from strength and we are
finally fat from strength and we're done
he's like all right sorry menagerie
shutting down like Calo sets it down if
there's a thematic and a story reason to
any of this yeah I'm I'm not good no
they're making a good point yeah making
a good point cuz like again again
narrative Lee if we get conclusion to
the calles story let's just oh so let's
say we you know kill them or whatever
whatever we technically can't be going
to the menagerie and hearing his voice
important that ship floats off into
space by the way shut out I've been
doing a lot of not really sure whoever
the voice actor is for cat he's
hilarious like I go to the menagerie to
listen to what he has to say every round
beiieving you with this and killing this
and talking about the enemy he's a lot
shout-out to Cali
I just feel like I got a glass of
something real opulent in my head
talking extra-strong it's just funny
very usual Aries South calles oh yeah so
I mean that's kind of the idea of these
Nightmare hunts could be really cool
you're gonna have different modifiers
you've got difficulties and the other
thing when you get to these monkeys
activities you're gonna have a really
hard encounters no matchmaking on the
950 power and you're gonna be looking
like why do I go in there and this goes
into like the difficulties they're
changing them up and this is where I
wanted to bring it act we've got a good
amount of chat and here I wanted to ask
you guys as well now that we have an
idea about power so we know 950
relatively hard cap the pinnacle cap is
960 and your artifact
we also learned
can get you an infinite power level
mm-hmm now it is gonna get harder the
higher you get it's probably gonna be an
exponential curve once you get hired to
a point but depending on how your power
level goes and how all of that stuff
works where do you think in four days
this rate is gonna lay in now or
question - mm-hmm do you think there's
gonna be more than one difficulty to
raid this time yeah I think multiple
difficulties come back um I don't think
we do we I don't think we touch this
whole power level briefly tighten it or
just yeah so yeah and then I just kind
of skim through it but we're going from
750 to 950 right 900 is the soft cap
we're basically anything you pick up
will help 909 50 is how it's done before
powerful rewards things like that then
950 to 960 is only gonna come from
Pinnacle activities most of us assume
raid maybe the dungeon
maybe these like her like legendary
nightmare hunts probably just the top
tier a few things to get those last 10
levels so I hashtag forever 29 no no and
then separate from that
well account-wide is your artifact right
so your artifacts can give you a bonus
power level which will hopefully affect
your incoming and outcome you know
incoming damage outgoing damage stuff
like that
it's account wide and it's just
experience based but there is no cap to
it Ben 1 right straight up said it's as
high as you spend the time in its
however many hours are in the day so I'm
know there's only so much you can play
so there's a limit somewhere but I mean
whether you can see 972 or 1000 you know
95 and have a stupid power jump it's all
going away at the end of the season
right so yeah I know I was trying to
fill that in so what I would have no no
no I love it I love it I think um I
think they may have found the balance
which is um the hard core balance and
what I mean by is that you know shout
out the Fram arabela
because we've had this discussion with
him at gcx and I've had concussions with
him offline offline as well
and the thing about it is that the grind
we all know comes down to RNG a lot of
times you need their arms you need that
boot it's holding you back you know me
and you can play the set amount of hours
but if you get lucky with the drops you
need you may be more raid ready than me
now what this system to me this how I
look at it when I see the artifact
system and I see this separate power
level that's independent of that that
you can add additionally by just playing
the game to me that rewards the hard
code that rewards to dedicate and that
to me is the ultimate bragging right
because that person's putting in the
work he's doing it he should be afforded
that you know also I love the fact that
they're getting back to pinnacle
activities rewarding stuff get [ __ ]
behind in the raid get your behind in a
shot it's wrong learn these things stop
staying wet like don't get me wrong
casual blueberries that we're gonna love
you and in october's you know Sam we
gonna love you you know Sam but we gonna
help you out and you got new light and
you got all the stuff you leave on the
level but there's great content that you
guys are not experiencing you know I'm
saying because of fear or whatever you
know so just maybe you don't have a
party whatever that's fine that's
understandable but this separation is
going to make you want to get in and
that's how I became I was the same
casual person in d1 right it was not
until that's why what's a glass of
beloved me isn't I did he was you're
gonna be with forever 950 but I'm gonna
be 951 yeah like I was like I didn't
know what level thirty huh how do you
get there if I'm saying like what and
then my boys like yeah you have to do
this thing and I'm like what is this and
it changed my life and I became rating
has been so much fun I'm doing
consistent like I want to but that's
what I think it's the pinnacle activity
I'm so glad I came across it and I think
they have to do this and it's smart
last point smart for engagement cuz
let's be real if there's a metric out
here
I'm gonna guess d2 raids
metric engagement hi that's all pyro go
over to I think he did cry
save got on ps4 three percent of people
had done last wish and that's your
biggest player base case in point I just
did cross safe right now when I did the
switch to I did the switch to p2 PC post
forsaken but I did last wish for the
first time completed it on PC right shot
the Mike Ibarra shot the Xbox crew to
help me throw all right I did cross save
came back to Xbox this week just to see
you know to see the functionality as
soon as I logged in Xbox achievement you
completed last mystery it now Xbox has
this diamond icon for rare achievements
that the rest of the population doesn't
have last quest came up at that three to
five percent time whatever that
percentage was so low that it came up as
a rare achievement that I conclude the
rain how crazy is that
yeah Oh sad is that because we all agree
right last where's taken King vault of
glass anyone at three is up there right
as for the best content people are not
experiencing so I love it man get them
in there make them do these pinnacle
activities and again they'll be fine at
nine whatever right there's nothing they
can't play together you won't be able to
do with stuff they'll be able to do
stuff but if you want that bragging
right do that and then I think about a
guy like you at last point what the
artifact you put in the work bro you put
in a work like you one of my favorites
everyone tent you know I'm saying and
you should be rewarded for the amount of
grind like when I come in I'm like okay
they got that 980 Danno alright he put
in the work though he did he did them
solo vids he did that chef he was doing
them dungeons yo you know I respect you
like respect that's what the hard core
needs gotta reward them with that and
it's it's balanced because at the end of
the season okay
clean slate then go hold or Wingo give
you seniority now you're gonna have as
960 verse 950 in that everybody can you
just let everybody can get to but it's
not so big of a disparity like 960 950
you'll have a smidge of an advantage and
this is the one er the gear advantage
will be there 952 960 you'll still see
that an iron banner
we'll see that in game innovations but
it's only ten points it's not huge right
but if somebody is like 75 plus power
level and then we're talking about iron
banner cam divisions my assumption is
the artifact will not affect your damage
in those places
I have probably not you'd think it would
be probably PvE yeah only yeah I would
think so I was like iron banner it's
gonna be wolf I'd be a mess yeah I
didn't know way to control it these guys
been around like you know 100 power but
there's only one question you didn't
answer
what's up what's one I missed okay so if
we go so power level of the right I know
we said difficulty normal and hard so if
you do two difficulties where do you
play some stuff 750 to 950 something
there Oh figure what is it Saturday
content laughs oh no Tuesday rain goes
live what a Saturday we start i sever 96
hours right we start at 750 Oh terrible
to stuff first encounter a D I don't
know normal for hard cuz he got four
days you might be able to do it normal
I'll say 850 which could work but then
say hard might be like 925 yeah
something like that
Jason jungnam and then probably the
final encounter of hard is probably
about 950 yes 960 depending what well so
I was like there's a lot of levels to
cover in a short time so if they don't
do two difficulties I really feel like
there that's not gonna find a good
balance either early or lane it's gonna
be too high too early or too easy too
late one of those yeah I think you're
right and I think that um they notice
they got the data
one thing I budget they see what's
happening to these these rates yeah
again world's first comes it's a
challenge topic to that point
then once people break through that's it
they're melting so you I think all of
this stuff is strategic the the whole
thing with um Luke with the supers and
the D buffs and all that that that this
is all setting up and then they're
letting us know Pinnacle contents gonna
get you out this is all setting up for
you to be in pinnacle content for
Pinnacle content to be harder I think we
probably do get a different their
difficulty mode I think this is what's
gonna probably solve those issues -
raves and stuff being that high level
content you know that it needs to be I
think that's the direction we're going
only we also got the Delta a hundred
levels now above that you can actually
still now do damage you might get worked
but you can actually do damage damage
100 levels above you in an activity well
that's different than 50 if it was 51
they were just the skull and you
couldn't touch him right out of it so
you can do it up to a hundred so there's
a lot of things around to these when
they talk about these difficult they
mentioned this is going into the new
nightfall system riot sure how that's
gonna work is this gonna be like adept
and hero and legend and they're just set
modifiers for the week and you just have
to deal with what's there wasn't gonna
be the night fault challenge card and
you can change some things up but some
are set like I don't there's a lot of
there's there they're giving us a lot
more option for challenge and definitely
ways to face harder content if we just
do yeah there's actually difficulties
you know they talk about those extra
level level bumps for like stuff like
knife or to add more significant
challenge they heard of us they got so
about two or three you know all choice
so they're doing things to wrap stuff up
and you know long as the rewards are
equate you know and are worth it I have
no problem with it I'm all for this
stuff I think this is they're on the
right path I think they're figuring it
out finally that balance that they need
for Pinnacle content as well as light
level you know there's still some
questions but for the most part for what
I'm hearing so far sounds good so yeah
we've got a lot so my god
I'm trying to even think through
everything we got this week so we got
this season
the gamescom trailer which kind of went
through a little brief preview of just
like shadow keep what's going on on the
moon we're dealing with Eris and that
and then we got the season of undying
trailer this was your favorite full
cinematic only but there is a reason
that the vex very specifically have gone
to the black garden or the garden of
salvation or whatever or that's the name
of the raid I should say and then when
you go
I love how Bungie is so like cheeky with
like calling describing things the
garden of salvation a signal emerges
from the dark and reaches beyond
dimensions into the uncharted wilds of
the black garden where it leads inside
the garden remains a mystery one that
whip whispers with temptation yearning
to be solved just that little bit of
like flavor text for the raid and
they're like I ain't gonna deck spurts
at this day good
yeah very well-written piece there so we
do also get to see a couple new exotics
and we have confirmed now just in case
there was a question we've got the hand
cannon with a scope gonna be using
special ammo so it's like a mini sniper
you've got the heaviest of heavy bike
chain bows hahaha that thing is a
monster by the way yeah begin and then
we've got there's a machine gun that
I've seen running around long Carlos
coming back Monte and then did you see
the season of undying armor have you
seen that picture on the page me raid
gear so lit light see I don't know
they're gonna show you raid gear though
no it's not I cash out the cactus he did
a good video on it as well I know you
talked about it um that man that that
stuff looks dude that Titan with those
two like gold that oh yeah my party's
looking good and yeah you can put your
space shaman away you can get this stuff
from a little bit you know what's funny
is growing on me I you were talking
about that we were talking offline I was
like and he's like people use in my my
my-y shaman picture I'm like what are
you talking about you hate that thing
he's like but but I feel like it's mine
now like
like a simulated but shall be now your
now you are an astro shaman there you go
yeah this blokes cool too because you've
got the hunter in the middle doesn't
look like he's got a big hood it's just
like the three eyes and the gold I mean
that stuff you look like we all look
like goblins walking oh it looks
freaking awesome so yes fire that's what
some of the best see I'm of a snag I
love that stinks now we're that amazing
no defend our moon from the vex invasion
that and face the undying mind now we
know the name the undying mind boss yeah
boss in the season of undying you'll
experience a new activity discover new
exotic weapons one of which is Monte
Carlo collect exclusive universal
ornaments and grow more powerful so
here's the thing when you look at the
couple frames we get of inventories you
see shadow keep weapons like all the
ones that look like they're wrapped in
the kind of the beads and feathers and
stuff like that and those have the
shadow keep ornament or the shadow keep
icon Monte Carlo has a little vex icon
it's different so what is resting so
does vex mean it came from a season but
potentially exotics don't go away so
that'll continue but then these seasonal
weapons like the moon ones that use the
seasonal artifact mods right won't have
their function come season 9 riot right
so you've got ooh you've get now they're
finding a way to actually take weapons
and say whether you like this or not it
may be ok in PvP but you're not gonna
bring this into PvE because you're gonna
get new weapons that are gonna go with
other mods so they're like they're
finding these gradual ways they're like
being generous and like yeah you can use
your armor you'll eventually get to
armor 2.0 yeah you can use this weapon
in PvP for a while if you like it but in
PvE you're probably gonna want the new
seasonal they're gonna make these like I
don't wanna say force shifts but they're
gonna start pushing us forward to like
start leaving things behind which is
something I'm happy about I know want us
to hold on to galavan for 12 years it
gets so boring it's just
it just it's not fun so I think this is
the subtle pieces of like I've been
trying to figure out my head it was like
well yeah so they have very specific mod
slots those aren't gonna do anything but
you can take these mods use them during
the season guess what you're gonna need
new armor too right
so all those things are gonna be yeah
they're finding ways to make you be like
do you really want to infuse your season
8 armor into season 9 maybe but it's
probably gonna not going to use the new
artifacts so then you're gonna be
getting new armor in the next season as
well so you've got this lake kind of in
and out like now working when you get to
new seasons I don't know what do you
think I it's interesting I read I think
this is a way that they try to solve a
lot of their long-term issues you know
I'm saying with the game and um I got to
see it the weapons I don't know though I
feel I do agree with you on some levels
you know I'm saying that like okay I'm
gonna go still work the same way in PvP
that's not gonna change so you're like
hey I got a really good set up I've got
a good role I don't even know if they're
ever gonna do weapons 2.0 but I doubt it
maybe I don't know but if you get a good
role and you like how that weapon feels
and it's good in the meta and it's like
a good 180 hand cannon that's not gonna
functionally change but if you take it
into PvE into the season in the future
you won't be able to use a future mod so
you will be kind of at a detriment so
old and where you use it hmm
it's interesting it's interesting with
this mod stuff or maybe it's it's almost
low-key forced retirement of certain big
legendaries yeah I'm saying so I think
exotics you know it's not gonna affect
it I don't see that but no yeah
legendary is definitely gonna again I
got a I got a C though it's one of those
thing I'm dramatically for it but I just
need to see it in action before I make a
final judgement whether this is
definitely the way to go you know I'm
saying because I don't make some people
go fall in love with certain things you
know say and it will there be pushback
well they're there yeah I mean you've
seen it before people are going wiping
up my whole vault and I'm like any
expansion in any other RPG just leave
your crap behind and get new stuff like
you don't with the only place really
I've ever
scene infusion can you know why bringing
stuff up you know here's the problem
they have because they're so damn good
with gunplay you form on it first of all
because it's a fps and like I said
Bungie is the master of gum play you
fall in love with these things you know
and you like yes my baby you're not
saying it to God roll on up now you
could still use it right but it's not
gonna have that functionality with that
extra little bonus thing I'm saying that
little bonus you ain't gonna have that
no more so to be interested you know I'm
to see a people you know still
begrudgingly are they just gonna be
forced to move oh yeah and that's kind
of that's a nice way to balance like if
there's a weapon you love how it feels
in PvP that you can continue to use you
won't lose that functionality if they
you know put all the numbers together
and it just like it fits really well for
you right but in turn like PvE will kind
of be a fourth shift of a PvP you can't
get the right you get the choice and I
think that's that's actually probably
gonna be okay and I just and I think I
enjoy those moments I've been goofing
around I've just been going through all
my solstice grind and is done all three
characters they're done it's finished
it's over thank God but I was losing one
through like different characters I was
just using whatever crap was on him I
wasn't really switching things over
going through I was just using what was
there just messing around and like
random some like some blue submachine
gun I was using I was like oh this
actually isn't so bad and actually he
recently got killed one and all this
thing's burning the mini-boss right now
cool mm-hmm there are moments of playing
we get all stuck in a rut yes this is a
nice way for them to just nudge you to
the next Rhett so like you get a little
little variety because some of this game
- I mean think about something like
Borderlands or Diablo oh I got a new bow
oh I got a different crossbow okay now
I've got a sword like you get a really
cool drop and you want to use something
different right we get so stuck on some
of these things that we don't want to
experience some of the cool stuff that
they made and is a nice way for them to
like steer you in to be like I mean this
time they've got auto rifles a hand
cannons and bows yeah those are your
mods that are gonna get those that are
doing those are the guns that get those
mods so auto rifles that I hope they can
buf by the way but they're gonna steer
you the autos and sub-machine-guns autos
and submachine guns in PVE they're gonna
steer you to those multiple times for
those mods like it's gonna change
possibly my plate and my go figure might
might sit Oh finally yeah yeah this man
is so ok I go figure and then I I was
like oh let me switch to another
character oh this is a bygones I hear
it's decent it's trash it's absolutely -
my go figure compete well the thing
about it is is the way the stats are set
up I have a counterbalance mod on it and
I have 85 recoil direction so that the
coil direction is just damn almost
perfect and it's like 90 range so I mean
there's only a blast furnace of
basically equivalent setup would take it
out of my slot so yeah it's funny though
talk about oh yeah it's been it's been a
thing but yeah I mean we had the VEX
season there's a couple screenshots the
the press kit has the images so the vex
invasion that goes along with the season
of undying there's a giant Minotaur on
the moon with a tree in his back yes you
have like goblins walking around with
leaves little chilly they'd be waiting
yeah they're just like alright I'm up
I'm up but the cool thing is I think
somebody stayed I figured if it was
Tassie maybe I think he said this is the
first time vex and I are gonna be
together yes yes very true first time
they may actually fight each other yes
want to see the motivations man want to
learn more ok this is cool stuff now I
even like to cinematics shout out the
defects milk creating these uh these
these monstrosities sort at in the trail
the radial radiolaria get a radial area
shared the bed oh that's great
interesting we have it gonna be it's
gonna be cool but I hope we get you know
why need this I need my man ashen we had
a talk his talk yeah I just
[Laughter]
yeah I could listen to as your beer it's
another way Calais right now Calais is
buddy might be take a - your spot but
top MPC's right now is definitely just
for pure laughs is definitely a
shimmying hilarious no I know I
literally laugh every time I do a strike
with them involved or the menagerie
I literally erupted in laughter while
I'm doing well
mm-hmm I'm trying to think who I would
have to pick I'm just waiting for Aris
more than anything
she just terrifies me but yeah that's a
good way a couple more things I know we
are at two hours guys but there's so
much to talk about
we're getting close to ours but there
are a couple things I didn't want to hit
from the song GamesRadar I will put the
link right here if you haven't seen it
they got a cool interview
I know podcast the fireteam shots gonna
have them on there today will so see if
they get any tidbits but we've got a
couple clarifications and a couple of
the screen shots they reminded me of one
of them
we have raid specific mods whoa let's go
so here's what activate active only in
the garden of salvation raid notice for
the season greatly increases oh-oh
greatly increases chances of finding
heavy ammo if you have the voltaic
overflow the voltaic overflow what in
the hell that means I don't know but I
mean it's a energy cost collector and
it's a yeah
it's a general armor mod so like you can
get raid mods and it stacks so you can
put four or five of these things on the
more of these mods you get the more
pieces of armor you get the more
benefits of wearing that armor in there
so actually finally looking at raid
using that raid set and having a benefit
in the raid feels we just were talking
about that's fantastic I just was
completed right and I saw that sounds
like that's my Bungie listening there we
go
so what I'm talking about man you gotta
get back to the sets gotta get back to
giving people advantages let's get back
to also little raid activities with the
gear rewarding the McKay
let's go swim talk about it it's an
extra slot yeah that can be
interchangeable so I want again I'm my
only question now is that rate gear say
if I was using it my question is if you
use that gear in other rays it's just
gonna be specific will this will the
raid slots be interchangeable per raid
gear or is it locked into there I'm very
curious about that probably probably be
locked in yeah it's probably for that
because it says only in the garden of
salvation on the pond and I assume
probably you're gonna need a new new
raid set to be using the raid mods
whatever self so that's one cool thing
like raids gonna have their own set of
armor which I don't know what that armor
could look better
oh yeah but it's got to if I'm gonna go
after it better look amazing too
but it's gonna have some cool mod slots
so here's a question I want to ask this
to chat and you as well brief touch on
it let's get it how many new strikes do
we get asking we get it we get two now
if you are on PC and Xbox we get access
to a third but for PlayStation 4 normal
Shadow keep we into new ones yeah one we
know of the Scarlett keep which is
likely to be a story mission because the
way that literally the flavor text is
like go investigation what's going on in
the Scarlett fortress it's like that
sounds like a story mission right the
other one is on IO and there's a brief
frame in one of the videos that says
pyramidion but what you're looking at in
there is not the pyramidion it's like
circular platforms and the peer mediums
on Io
so somebody actually joked when I was in
twitch and they said well what if we're
actually going to the radio Larian lake
the pastor mere joked about talking
about he said that we don't see that oh
yeah that was good yep that could very
well be we gonna get my boy back
ashes mag baby it's on so you won't he
will
we be talking to you on that one and
that would make sense because it's vex
you know vex for the season makes sense
as well there so I'll be curious but it
said pure MIDI and so I'm wondering if
it's like version two because it said
the exact same name but I can tell you
around that strike two many times that
platform did not exist in there
everything in the pyramidion is a very
boxy and square and angular very
everything in that picture was round
mm-hmm so I was like this is weird mm-hm
so we get two strikes are you okay with
to which it was more or less okay it was
more but you know looking into not gonna
get too crazy but everything else they
given us you know saying it kind of get
in the past with that and I'm getting in
touch too crazy but you know hopefully
after this get back into this kind of
cadence per season even if it's one
strike a season I'd be okay it's more
than I've had on it's one only the more
we have we need strikes though it just
makes the flavor of it the variety so so
much good so yeah I'm with that yeah I
mean a one set - it's like we see how
extensive the nightmare hunts are like
what's involved in those mm-hmm
and then also we have a vex activity
that's on the map that we don't even
know what it is yeah because you look at
the map you got Nightmare hunts you got
strike the raid looks like it's in the
corner bottom left is just some vex
circle and it's a weekly challenge and I
have no idea what that is you know cool
ring it's a round rectangle it's a
rounded rectangle could be your jaw
they're like what are nightmare hunts
are there dungeons like shadow keep or
more like Forsaken barren hunts there
new activity we're not talking about
them so we're not telling you they do
say something here when it comes to what
will activities what activities will
support the new adept hero in legend
difficulty modes these difficulty labels
you saw are part of the evolution of the
nightfall system we're adding new
difficulty tiers to challenge players
that's one small taste of what some of
these extra levels will be and the
activities though apply to in shadow
keep there's a lot of extra details
we're not going into so that's the basic
of them saying we're gonna have new
difficulty options right in a lot of
places now here's my only thing Oh what
makes me want to go run her oak
menagerie menagerie menagerie whatever
you want to say
no not that back sword right no I mean
that's this is literally what I'm
getting - yeah if you go from 950 to 960
that's gonna be some of the reason to
run but there on the other side is like
why why do I need to run in a nightfall
at bananas difficulty at legend
difficulty with six modifiers and is
that's the thing it's like strike
exclusives I need I need some reason to
go bash my head against the crazy walls
and that's one thing the rewards have
been somewhat lacking in a lot of places
oh absolutely especially for guys like
you you say yeah it's difficult content
I mean if I go one sorry go ahead
no no no I was just gonna say if I go
run shattered throne I just get dreaming
city gear that I get from anywhere else
I don't get anything I'd had there's an
exotic quest in there but there's not a
shattered throne set of armor there's
not shattering weapons nothing nothing
special comes from there it's just it's
another twilight oath
it's another raid on helm it doesn't
matter it didn't matter it was the
simple the accomplishment to do it but
you didn't get anything there's not like
Dolan Cara's not dropping a specific
exotic like vex mythoclast from there
it's there's no actually there's no like
oh I didn't get it let me go again like
Ryder's Nolan was arrived to go back
there once I've checked that box I'm
done right and to me this is a way you
they can bring back skeleton keys this
is a way you know what I was thinking -
how about another very rare item that is
really cool is the curated role how
about curated roles being it will make
the best though yeah but like if you
look at the curated blast furnace I can
make a better version by the mod pool it
should be a damn good version it should
be the version and thereby they thought
it was not in their mind Oh clearly in
that day body just made it they just
though they just do it Randy I'm sorry I
think feeding frenzy and rampage is
better than what else or whatever else
you're gonna give me on my blast furnace
so what no it's disagree
all I'm saying for whatever reason they
put go it's really not my root old tale
isn't bad could be a little better but I
mean there's always like
like I guess I don't know how those role
in the loot pool if those are like a
more frequent occasional option I think
it was em - - ran and grind it out like
Mindbenders ambition he got like 30 of
them ran the strike and God knows how
many times
Wow but he had like out of 30 he had
like seven or eight curated it's almost
a third were the same role so maybe it
shouldn't be the god god rule but who
knows but I still want yeah it's the one
good to me no just gonna say some need
to be a little better go ahead no no I
think it's just one of those things that
we know like I said the the chance the
probabilities are so low for getting
that stuff so how about increased that
reward bang increase that probability
you know reward guys like you like look
like for example the Solstice gear right
which I'm waiting on you oh yeah yeah
I'm waiting I put in my application I've
been waiting oh you finally got the
congratulations not help me do all do
some next week thank you sir so um yeah
like look at that there even one of the
requirement is do shadow throne you know
one to two player all right how bout II
when you do that solo you know I'm
saying that should be Pinnacle reward
that is in extreme you and esoterics
yeah psychopath level your good clothes
like I'm a big you my man is my me is
nice no they give I'm okay not good
you know get yo give yourself no credit
but yeah like yo give out some cool give
out some curity roles give out a skill
give out something give out strike
specific give out something then when my
man does this you my yo where did you
get that how did you get that the solar
boy so little chatty since we're talking
about shatter throne war black pot
brought it up earlier so there is a
piece of lore and this is why I'm
wondering with our power level that's
coming
mmm if it's now or if it's like next
season then it says if you defeat Dolan
karu
alone at 999 power
level you in the curse of the dreaming
city mmm that's a piece of lore buried
somewhere that's real that's real enjoy
what I send that one out and let's be
how long do you think that might have
been in the works and honestly it's all
the curse has to end at some point it
has to end we have to we can't just
leave them in purgatory I to me that's
fun not a sad thing is will you lose
your [ __ ]
that's seed and the take you had no I I
have so load that thing flawlessly so
how do you system so if I'm it says the
triumph literally is called seriously
never again I'm okay with that very cool
experience and it's one of those I wish
they could do late almost like an
archive playlist for if they do take
stuff out they never bring a shadow
throne is really amazing like just to go
through the fact I'll see it all the
fights the encounters I mean it's a
really cool place for three people to go
through together so I don't know if well
we will ever truly wrap it up mm-hmm
what are you okay with some guardians
never experiencing how many people
probably don't even want to I mean
people don't want to do raids hey I got
my gun again it comes back to I guess
it's like yeah I've experienced it
honestly I wish everybody could
experience it cuz I love that place but
if they wrap it up and if they if that
is the way it's wrapped up or maybe it's
only your game maybe if you still load
at nine nine nine you can't get to it
anymore
I don't know but like but if there is
some but if they wrap it up with regards
to lore and story and progression of the
world then I think that's cool because I
think that shows like just an evolution
the damn dreaming city every time you
talk to Petra she's just like huh yeah
I'm like I feel sorry for men yeah
perpetual torment Perpetua Tommy anybody
and you're right in narrative Lee is
dope like for that to end that'd be a
good way to like you got it you got a
1v1 bill in Cairo at nine nine nine
that's like that's crazy good now that
what would be really cool is if you win
in and it was like just an arena like
you win it at 999 it was just you and
her and it was there was actually a
different area they like built it
separate yes yeah I go for it though
stuff that we used to feel away doing
things man look everybody loves the
ascendant room not everybody knows none
ah it's fine you know
I like it not everybody does it gives me
tension but the whole like artistically
like you feel like you in some nether
realm and that the space and if you feel
like the coldness of like space like it
is [ __ ] forsaken man that is deployed
literally throw that stick so weird go
well we will see
we're ii was amazing cuz we got tangled
shore giant surprise of dreaming city
last wish rail or continuation shattered
throne dungeon like that
Aldrin that's why I'm saying the whole
forsaken dreaming city all that yeah the
older in decayed kill in case I wake up
oh yeah well Kate died like that's a
whole lot that goes on wrong yeah to go
to go expansion not even close right now
like I don't know what other experience
is gonna do and what I do say we did say
an effort a game that is it but right
now yeah this is up there he was amazing
no sample yeah the Forsaken is too cold
man I go to the dream city I'm just like
this is amazing
a couple more bits from the GamesRadar
article yes sir
ask about gambit and gambit Prime no I
will honestly tell you guys by the way
I've been playing my fair share of
gambit I have been timing those matches
yeah he wist it was the beta prime
shorter okay I'm just straight-up saying
it like now I will also say when you
guys are like gambit or game but
probably if you were the first one up
and regular gambit know how'd you get
invaded a lot hmm I think like yeah
regular game but you get invaded plenty
game a prime one round if you get
stomped at least it's short but even if
you go long I still match a normal game
to match so prime is shorter for sure
okay oh now you've been playing more of
it you are leaning prime as so okay
here's okay I have to just tweaks so one
I don't care how many invasions you've
stockpiled if you deposited your crap
early if you're Prime Evils done you do
not get to into in vain until we get to
invade earn so we're up to prime evil
face cuz it's like oh we have 18 motes
in there and then you got a high eagle
and but they haven't invaded because
they just stopped us at one point and
then we're trying to get back in
somewhere at about 50 we're getting
ready to deposit then they invade again
a more like we can't you can't catch up
at that point you do truly get stomped
so like if you don't invade before
you're Prime Evils up those all get
wiped out that needs to me I think that
would be a way for you to be like
alright come on we gotta kill stuff we
got a deposit and you can invade and you
have that because if you lose any
progress at all at that point that tug
of war is just it's done goes to the
other team so I mean that is one
invasions happen too much in both modes
doesn't matter which one it's just too
much in both heaviest steel bunkers yeah
so this very I'm where a moment do
because I honestly did not use a heavy
machine-gun for this entire grind mmm I
did not use my hammer head once I was
using grenade launchers for damage I was
using sniper rifles and random stuff
mm-hmm but I did not use a heavy machine
gun once mmm and it's really hard to
compete against them like they are they
are on their own
I mean and everybody knows it but it's
just like if you don't run one you
running at a disadvantage absolutely
mm-hmm I was playing bender last night
for the last few matches and yeah I mean
I went through a couple matches where it
was literally a hundred to zero and then
we had another one where it was about
five or six to a hundred I mean the lit
that I don't know why and I think it's
just the number of invasions on the
heavy but the disparity between some
matches is so big so Dave that's my
thing it just no how it flips so hard
it's not consistent that's one of my
first because it's like there are times
when you like damn I'm not getting any
heavy I'm Lisp I can't defend against an
invasion I can't do tremendous you know
DPS against the boss you know based on
what your energy and universe are you
have some energy or you know not a
strong kinetic it's just like it's it
you feel helpless you know and that's my
part with gambit crime that can get
annoying when you don't have it and then
it's a DPS phase and then you know here
they come with the invasion during the
you know it's just certain little
aspects of it you know I don't hate it
hate it I just feel I got a tweak if it
comes out of prom staying fine but you
got a tweak you they they need some
tweaks well here's your words of gambit
and gambit prime which is news by the
way because this wasn't actually true
until like right now which are both
available to new light yes
so both are going to new light are not
going more anytime soon right
and basically it's taste I'm not going
into where it's old destiny both of
these activities will be available
through year 3 so they're both staying
around through year 3 it's interesting
know they said that we got this update
based on what Luke had said previously
because Luke didn't say it time anybody
Connie any almost almost felt like a
coming soon yeah hanging around still
longer I think they might just think
work on tweaks on both and see if they
can kind of see what happens I think for
people who bought the Annual Pass they
can't dump reckoning and prime and the
sets and stuff they don't they don't
want to jack that content away because
they haven't run set that precedent yet
I just said at some point just like with
crucible we're changing we were changing
the playlist set up how gambit and gamma
Prime more
work that stuff didn't happen around
shadow keep won't don't expect it to
happen when shadow keeps lunches though
so it'll happen later right but it's
just one of those things so yeah we've
got infinite power cap we've gotten
grade specific mods and gear
we've got seasonal spinnings we've got
shadow keep things we've got temporary
activities we've got a moon that is
bigger it's twice as big and I was
literally going through the map to where
we've got archers lying mm-hmm
blinking now because I can't see the
maddinames but yeah you have the two the
main three zones the middle zone is
completely overtaken Helmand Hellmouth
is overtaken out and then you've got
some Harbor like Sorrows Harbor up north
witches may be where the actual fortress
is because I don't know if the big thing
in Hellmouth is gonna be like the wall
and the door and the ins like work your
way back to it or if that's something
separate we've got four lost sectors
which are new to explore okay okay
you have the Fallen catch which lands
down by anchor of light down there where
you used to the worse at public event is
looks like where that thing is hard yeah
because you have because you'd get in
the anchor of lighting you have like the
buildings on that side that were kind of
like up the side you have the big
mountain in the middle and then you had
the dome and then you had the we've
awoken the hive like the set of
buildings like near that entrance back
there and then up in the front and that
kind of little front outcropping was the
mumbling event and that looks like where
the Fallen caches parked or crashed or
whatever - and whatever yeah yeah yeah
so you've got a ship for lost sectors
you've got the sanctuary which is down
below on the bottom of the map I don't
know if that goes down to anything or if
that's just a little strip of land and
then just like on dreaming city and Rea
Sylvia up in the north where you kind of
go off the map yeah there's a place to
do that as well so I'm always quick
question no you're getting uhm so
redacted still is redacted right oh it's
redacted this nightmare stuff no
hradecká story actually I'm still
getting redacted
on top it is that's probably the
seasonal vex turquoise bubble that I
don't know what the hell is yeah so even
if we don't really and some patria like
hey I hope we get to explore the black
garden and I'm like outside of the raid
I don't see us doing much there might be
a quest to get it open I don't see us
hanging out in there a lot it would be
cool but I don't see us hanging out in
there a lot hmm but yeah that's I mean
this week has been a huge info dump and
we're gonna get a little more as we go
but this has been massive this week this
has been like oh they're just knocking
it out Oh tons of stuff this is the best
it's the best time when you step the way
I said like there's nothing better than
destiny like right or a major expansion
and it's just news after news after news
and I always like to September really
because it always feels like a
reimagining of the ant a matter of
taking looking at this content and then
just like I can't but you bender man I
can't with you brother well yeah yeah
it's like you know this this is a really
amazing content and then again we still
haven't gotten to the PvP stuff we still
got stuff we still don't know about
radec tons man times cannot wait
cannot wait man this is these are good
times it's good to be a destiny fan
right now
so yeah I think we can honestly wrap it
up here for today yes sir uh thank you
guys in chat who have been being been in
here all day chatting up making us laugh
having a good commentary giving us ideas
to talk about you guys have been on fire
so thank you guys for judging it if you
did not catch this live you're catching
it later twitch.tv slash Yvonne tests
just check our Twitter's all three of
them you'll see when we go live but
outside of that
kognito if you want to wrap it up let
them know what you got going we will let
these people get to their Friday yeah
man well before I do that I'll shout to
sassy saucy
hello I'm new here that's what's up but
uh thanks for the style bag came at the
end you
but I'll be a gracious make sure you
guys please all we have on Twitter we
have the last word on Twitter account so
but I'm gonna actually drop that in chat
it's at last word pod so please make
sure you follow check it out man support
what me and Eve artists are doing so I'm
just doing an in chat as well and then
as well as Lords of gaming got net when
you get a chance you can catch we have a
last word section there and you can
catch the latest article it also more
Cognito is a little bit more in-depth
takes there and I'm saying are certain
little subjects or little pieces of the
table that I like to focus on and stuff
like that but as far as me per se you
already know at Laura kognito on Twitter
and on annual podcasters on YouTube
every Sunday is the Lord's Day we'll
have a cool guest it will be Danno Taj
it was there the man the myth he will be
in the building Twitch's finest we're
gonna talk that we gotta talk a little
destiny cuz he knows that's me well as
well as our mole stuff he's organizing
as well as gcx he's uh one of the PR
guys which is put it together a lot of
cool charitable efforts for st. Jude so
please that Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern
check me out the rest of the crazy Lords
we will be talking gaming multi-platform
gaming and all that good stuff and of
course Friday mornings you already know
where he's supposed to be at the
campfire with your beverage with me
anybody's chilling you know then
generally 9:00 a.m. which on eat parties
and of course later up on YouTube if you
miss us live catch us on the iron law
podcast youtube channel as well as he
launches his channel to channel as well
that's what I got sir he you muted no no
I mean for me just continuing to break
down this footage I think I'm gonna
probably dig into the exotics next if
you guys haven't caught a couple of my
videos I went hardcore onto the
artifacts we've got four mods what they
can all do some builds possibilities and
then this one I went into the moon and
the activities we're gonna get so full
walkthrough of the map kind of broke
that one down by cropping a couple
pictures together so you can see most of
what we've got for the map all the
activities we're going to
to some modifiers with those have the
artifact ties in there a couple long
videos but we're getting deep dive into
pretty much everything for the moon so
I'm gonna probably go through exotics
next and so stay tuned to the YouTube
channel there so if you haven't
subscribed to that one please do so over
36,000 guys thank you for all the crazy
for it that is awesome
so yeah twitch and twitter you guys know
where to find me i'm streaming now this
is i don't know if this is gonna happen
this Saturday but my brother gave me the
idea some point guys I've got to clean
up my vault huh so he gave me the idea
heads the heads up this might not be
g-rated but potentially to have a two to
three lemon drops in possible drunk
stream vault clean-out ASMR chat voting
on it above so yes that eat this y'all
that has to happen probably it's
probably like a Saturday night if I
don't have any plans on Sunday because
if yeah it's got to happen do we get
that vote everybody knows about your
vote my house is awful so at some point
that may happen so turn on your Twitter
notifications in case you see it you
might catch me drunk vault clean out for
the win burned it all leave it in the
past yes I've got some support on this
one so yeah get some beverages flow and
apparently it's all I got I got I got a
pop through you know say unless I say
yeah yeah itself I will tweet I don't
know if it's this weekend I gotta find a
good weekend for it this weekend my work
but we'll see and then how much working
out I'm doing but that will have to
happen so that no no word no no what
start with the go figure
did you chalice is very Bowie they will
put that go figure to bed but yes that
will be coming up so thank you guys very
much it's been an awesome episode got
more guests in the works
of course I got some cool ones were
working on so we'll let you guys know
when we have finalized dates they're
definitely once you guys won't want to
miss so you guys have been awesome we
wouldn't be able to do this without you
guys so thank you and for everything
it's me and see bonta's over there it's
lion Lords podcast
you don't know him go find him go watch
him go listen to him keep him in your
earholes they will keep you entertained
and and up-to-date with all the good
things and for episode 70 August 23rd it
has been the last word